der ex wirecard chef markus braun wurde
heute festgenommen
das hat die staatsanwaltschaft münchen
bekanntgegeben und die staatsanwältin an
allerdings steht jetzt bei meinem
reporter karl heim in münchen wohl einer
der größten die langstreckenfahrt der
geschichte der deutschen
der deutschen geschichte jetzt wird eben
hier die oberstaatsanwältin andere
leiding von der staatsanwaltschaft mit
den einzigen was wirft die
staatsanwaltschaft münchen 1 dr markus
braun vor die haben ja am sonntag nacht
auf montag früh einer ad hoc mitteilung
der wallfahrt zur kenntnis genommen und
haben dann eben erkannt dass wir da sich
daraus der verdacht der
marktmanipulation und der unrichtigen
angaben ergibt auch gegen den
beschuldigungen mögliche weitere
mittäter haben dann einen haftbefehl
beantragt auch erlassen bekommen und der
beschuldigte hat sich eben dann gestern
abend bei der stadt hof münchen 1
gestellt
wie geht es jetzt weiter sitzt dr brown
schon in untersuchungshaft
also erst jetzt aufgrund des haftbefehls
bereits in vorläufiger haft wird
allerdings heute am frühen nachmittag
noch der ermittlungsrichterin vorgeführt
die dann über die haftfortdauer
entscheiden wird wie sie da das konzept
von wirecard aus kredit dazu etwas sagen
wie haben die das gemacht ist sollen ja
wohl 19 milliarden euro fehlen irgendwie
dir angegeben wurden also wir gehen
neben davon aus dass ist der
der verdacht auf dem haftbefehl zugrunde
liegt dass er eben sozusagen die bilanz
und umsatz aufgebläht wurden um
sozusagen die wirecard als
finanzkräftiger darzustellen als sie
tatsächlich wahr und bietet die weiteren
entwicklungen aus wie schwierig ist dass
so etwas nachzuweisen
das ist natürlich sehr sehr komplex
insbesondere ist für uns noch nicht ganz
klar welche weiteren fälle wie er auch
noch zu untersuchen haben also zum
beispiel dann diese unrichtige bilanz
vorgelegt wurde um weitere kredite bei
anderen banken zu erlangen
und natürlich ist ein internationales
unternehmen wir werden da also
wahrscheinlich in die ganze welt
ermitteln dürfen es gibt ja jetzt schon
hinweise eben auf diese zwei bankkonten
auf den philippinen
das macht es nicht unbedingt einfacher
aber wir gehen davon aus dass wir das
ermitteln können werden könnte dazu
sagen entwickeln sie dann auch gegen
diesen inhaber dieses treuhandkonto auf
den philippinen daher auch ein anwalt
sein soll also zu diesem sehr sehr
frühen stadium der ermittlungen möchten
wir noch nichts zu möglichen weiteren
beschuldigten sagen da waren die
einschätzungen der staatsanwaltschaft
mit denen von oberstadt mit den
anleitungen und und damit knapp